hi I'm Julia and 24 years old and I'm
Italian I study human rights at
university and I'm really involved in
volunteering I'm Jan European traders
Corp at the end of the my master's
degree because I was looking for new
opportunities not only in the voluntary
sector but for support training myself a
new job opportunities and so I shifted
occasional because that was the word
Huizar it isn't so attractive and I
really believe in solidarity
I started my European soil for placement
at PD three weeks ago your pml-n Center
I'm a project and policy assistance
there so I'm following project and being
a helpful for the new policies of each
from this experience I think I would
like to learn more about how to manage a
project and I'll control it later and
also as you be really proactive in the
European Union